you see all the best people are crazy
you can't be not crazy and be the best
when there's crazy people out there who
want to be the best
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like my days
yeah i'm gonna actually start by asking
you a question i was just talking to uh
ben about this would you send your kids
to a school
and
let them get hit or like not hit but
like
it's not the right word but like if
you're acting like an [__] they can
grab you by the collar and kind of push
you against the wall are you okay with
that
no
you're not okay with that i'm not okay
with that and it's not because i don't
want my kid to get hit it's that i
wouldn't trust
the person who would be doing the
hitting to know
the the right way and the wrong way and
the right where the line is because i
just think about it this way if you're
the type of teacher who signs up for
that
like
if you're the type of teacher who goes
to this specialty discipline school the
specialty abuse school
uh to teach
like i just don't want that person have
a screw loose and i'm not there to see
it so i would rather err on the side of
no you can't hit uh my kid or like rough
them up in any way
um
unless i'm kind of like i know this
person i trust this person i'm there or
whatever like like for example i think
if it was a coach of some kind and the
coach was really tough on my kid i don't
know about hitting but like
you know kind of punking my kid totally
cool with that as long as the coach is
legit but i've seen a whole bunch of
people and actually grown up now and
look back at some of the teachers and
coaches i had who kind of did weird
stuff and now that i'm an adult i'm like
oh
this was just a totally flawed person at
the time i really like i thought they
were the authority i thought that they
must know things that we don't know and
then now i see them on facebook and
they're posting like crazy anti-vac
stuff and they're like you know like
preppers and stuff like that i'm like oh
you know you kind of always just had a
screw loose and at the time i thought i
was the i was in the wrong for not not
you know
not uh playing by your rules or whatever
i went
at my i went to all boys high school and
i was a you know i was a jerk at the
time and there was times where like the
guy the disciplinarian like you're
supposed to have your shirt tucked in
and i would if i didn't have it untucked
and i got yelled at a bunch of times
they would come up and like give you
like a horrible wedgie like they would
grab you by the underwear and lift you
up and like what if i told you someone
about this and or like if i like you
know i was disrespectful a couple times
and they just would grab me by the shirt
and push me against the lager and
they're like if i hear from this again
you're over you know what i mean and i
loved it was it a military school it's
just a boys school no it was just an
all-boys catholic college prep school in
st louis where i'm from that was your
house
yeah you went to all boys high school
and what about like before that
i went to in st louis the way it works
is most
people in my area
go to private school and like so i went
to a catholic k-8 and then
uh eight to twelve all-boys
college prep catholic school at the time
it was like 900 a year uh st ambrose my
grade school so it's like that's just
what everyone did
all right what do we uh what do you want
to talk about today can we talk about uh
your tweet that went viral that was
pretty cool
your boy's done it again another hit how
many how many people did it reach
uh 5 million something like that wow
so
what you wrote
honestly just wasn't even that
interesting so i i'm very surprised
pretty cool
i would say it was pretty cool i think
the reason i only thought it was pretty
cool was like because i already know you
and i know how you think the cooler
there was two cool parts about it this
the the the one it was okay it was good
it was like a 8.5 out of 10 in sight
number two
the thing that's a 10 out of 10 was the
fact that you just thought of it like
that that you just it was a pretty
original thought i think and uh like you
broke it down that was a 10 out of 10.
and one of the other thing that was a 10
out of 10 was that you reached amazing
people so bill backman bill ackman if
you don't know
five or ten billion dollar person
uh kind of
a little bit like a god in the hedge
fund world he actually retweeted it and
he said incredible
incredibly interesting insight or
something like that yes and
i thought that was amazing i thought
that was so cool and i think that for
the listener the takeaway here is like i
know you and you're kind of a big deal
now but like three years ago you weren't
a big deal and now you're basically like
one you're
like if you dm'd bill ackman or loads of
other people
or you call their email you have access
to them
and that's pretty amazing about
the internet it's it's true it is
amazing
how these things go i'll tell you some
cool things that happened um
i don't know why i want to tell you this
i like i i guess i would never really
say if if i would just think of this
like a podcast i would never say this on
the podcast because it sounds like why
you bragging but like
if i just think about this like i'm just
talking to sam i'd be like dude you
won't believe what happened and so i
tweet this thing out
it
um and i i guess for people who don't
know what it is i guess i tweeted a
thing that was like um
the uh
it was about the metaverse which is like
the dorkiest term you know ever so you
know already i feel lame even talking
about my it's lame to talk about a tweet
it's lame to talk about the metaverse
i'm multiplying two lames together um
but basically what happened is uh
facebook rebranded or renamed the
company to meta and so it was kind of
top of mind for a lot of people and i've
been hearing a bunch of people talk
about the metaverse kind of in the
investor circle like i remember when we
had um who was it that we had on here
mike maples i think it was and he was
like he was talking about big trends
that he had kind of bet on in the past
and we said what trends are you betting
on now and he said like you know the
shift to remote work
this other thing and he goes and the
metaverse
and like we didn't even really talk
about it on the episode but i remember
stashing that away as like huh
this pretty legit guy said he's betting
on the metaverse and like
i i don't even i don't know what a
metaverse company is and so i just kind
of stash it away as like something i
should probably go look into at some
point
and um so i basically wrote a thread
that was like
hey i think the way that people think
about this is uh
is wrong so
i thought about it originally i thought
about it the way i think most people do
which is the metaverse is a place if
you've ever read or watched the movie
ready player one it's kind of like oh
there's a virtual world like second life
or like you know whatever there's this
virtual world we're all gonna go live in
a video game it's like a video game life
basically and that's what people i think
it's just the sims with with the with
the headset
yeah like you're plugged in it's some
some version of the matrix already
player one or people have these
different mental models from like books
or movies that they've seen and
i said i don't i actually i don't think
it's a place i don't think that the
metaverse is just like one giant
minecraft world that we're all gonna go
live in and hang out in and play in and
work in and all that stuff i don't think
it's like one company creates this this
game and we all go live in it
um i said instead i said what if it's
not a plot what if we're wrong about
that what if it's not a place what if
it's um a time i was like what does that
mean well a time i basically described
this like parallel so in in the ai world
um for artificial intelligence this idea
of the singularity and it's this moment
where like
kind of like technological progress just
sort of escapes us it just it's uh it
starts accelerating faster than you know
uh we can imagine and in rough speaking
terms this is where the doomsday people
think you know it's after this that
basically the robots you know the
artificial intelligence takes over and
humans are done and then other people
think it's utopia where
artificial intelligence can just invent
things it can create cures for cancer
and whatever else and humans will be
saved and like we will all have to just
we all just will have hobbies we don't
have to work because ai just takes care
of everything
but there's this idea of the singularity
and it's this moment in time where ai
basically surpasses this threshold
so i was basically arguing with my my
idea was
i think the metaverse is actually a time
it's a moment in time where
we care more about the things in our
digital life than in our physical life
and care more doesn't mean like oh i
don't care if my body gets hurt or dies
right that's not really what i meant but
like
if you spend all your time working
online
and then you communicate with people who
are also online and you don't even
really know them in real life you're not
talking to your neighbor you're talking
to this person on twitter or this person
in a discord this person on reddit and
then your watch all of your
entertainment is streamed to you online
and all of your assets are digital
assets like cryptocurrencies and things
like that so you know your money is
digital like once everything goes
digital and more and more things go
digital at some point there's a tipping
point
where
you basically your identity your assets
your social life
it's all online and i said that to me is
the metaverse and it won't be one
company it'll be a combination of
companies that are all doing that and i
kind of gave some examples like you know
uh a filter and instagram is basically
like a a better superior replacement to
cause you know getting plastic surgery
or um wearing heavy makeup right like
the digital filter matters more is
cheaper more accessible to more people
because
ultimately you care how you're seen
online almost more than you care how
you're seeing in person right like i
know plenty of people that would never
they would never post a photo of them
with their hair messy and their sweats
and their oversized t-shirt they would
never post that on instagram but they'll
go to the grocery store like that
because who cares i don't care what
these people think but i really care
what those people think so what i was
describing was that this is already
happening there's this long-running
shift that's happening where you're
caring more about your digital
reputation your digital identity your
digital assets than your real world
stuff
and i said to some people this is going
to be like sound like the worst thing
ever some people think i think this is
the best thing ever and not my argument
it's not even it's neither the best nor
the worst it's just the way that things
are going and you'll make of it what
whatever you choose so anyways
you tweet this on like friday or
thursday
and yeah what happened
at first nothing really happened uh it
kind of did how i thought it would do
initially so initially i was like oh
it's kind of an interesting idea but
pretty like nerdy and in the weeds and i
don't think anyone's gonna care
and it kind of didn't do much at the
beginning and then something happened
and it just started picking up steam
like it's it's getting more like
yesterday it had even more mentions
because uh
this you know fred wilson is
uh the vc yeah the vc from union square
ventures he's had this blog that like
for a long time i think it's like
freddie gracie or something like that
he's been blogging for like 15 years
i've read his ideas for so long and he
made a post his post today was the
metaverse he goes i read this really
insightful thing and he just embedded my
tweet he's like it made me think blah
blah blah and something against a new
spike of people or whatever and so yeah
so i didn't expect it i want to know
what happened
so okay so the first thing is after how
many people followed you because of it
let's see i started at 178 178 000
followers
and i now have 193 and a half thousand
so
193.5 we don't do public math but we can
add this up 15 000 new followers
the post itself has about 20 000 plus
likes but i'll tell you what was that
that's that's okay that's the that's the
cool part that's numbers but here's what
was fun
i get a call from uh
uh we'll have to bleep this out but i
get a call
right after i post it about 15 minutes
later i get a call from uh
and you know
basically i'll bleep that out but
basically a uh
a famous person who has stuff on netflix
and they go
dude
i'm tripping out over here i i go what
and they've never called me before
friends
he had after i so i did that clubhouse
threat a while back and this person had
dm me saying hey that's like that's so
on point blah blah blah and they said
hey if i ever come to san francisco you
know for for you know uh you know some
of my profess my my hollywood work
then um
then i'll i'd love to you know hang out
or something and i just i was like yeah
right and but i gave him my number and
so i get a phone call from the person
and then they say dude i'm tripping out
over here you know like it made me a
little bit anxious uh like this this is
like what's gonna happen like
i think you're right but i don't know
what it means if you're right so anyways
we have this like little conversation
that was kind of fun
and then it starts going into um a bunch
of nfl players started following and i'm
like why would they care and so a bunch
of pro athletes followed and um and so
then i'm you know sliding into their dms
or they're sliding into my dms i'm just
basically it's like clear the calendar
all day i'm just going to be answering
direct messages because really so i
don't know who's in here but i know a
lot of values in here
so
uh uh professional athletes
yeah a bunch of people from the tech
industry which you would expect and then
anyone intriguing
uh from the tech world
um yeah
yeah i think for i mean fred wilson i
felt pretty good about uh like a bunch
of the andrewson guys who had blocked me
from the clubhouse thread
some of their partners well the people
who blocked me probably didn't didn't
didn't reply they didn't unblock me for
this but some of the other partners
messaged and said hey this is you know
this is great and i said okay i'm glad
i'm not just permanently banned from uh
from from your office servers that's
awesome i think that's great so this is
cool stuff happens and then uh you know
the other thing is that a bunch of
people
and i realized this later which is
i thought kind of like you know even if
you you have one of these twitter
threads that goes viral who cares like
ultimately what does it lead to it's fun
but you know who gives a [__] but i've
seen now months later there was a lot of
people who are like let's say i want to
go invest in a company they're like dude
i remember that thread that was epic and
they're just like you're cool right you
just get this stamp because in a world
where it's so noisy there's so many
people
if you do one memorable thing that
people respect and like
it's like that's the shortcut in their
brain that says okay i like this person
yeah i trust this person yeah they're
cool it's like just from that that's not
like i wouldn't have ever predicted that
so anyways i call these like my little
serendipity engines it's like i put it
out there in the world and i could never
predict what's gonna happen but then all
these like kind of second and third
order consequences end up happening
where you end up meeting somebody going
to dinner doing a deal like it's just
all this weird stuff that you can't
predict so fun day uh when this happens
but also
such a weird thing dude like i couldn't
imagine even if you told me five years
ago 10 years ago like this would be a
thing in my life that i would care about
i'd be like what are you talking about
why would i care about that
yeah i think it is pretty unique and i
think that
i met this guy named blake uh i don't
know what his name is blake b but i went
to oklahoma city when i was driving
through and i had like a mfm meetup or
like a sampar meetup i don't know what
it was and i hosted like 20 people for
breakfast and this guy came and they're
like what would you tell us if you if we
want to i forget what the even question
was i go man get on twitter it's where
it's happening and he's on it now and he
signed up whenever i did this thing a
year ago now he's got like 50 85 000
followers 50 70 i forget
what's his name blake bird you probably
see him in like the little circle jerk
and uh he was at the meetup he didn't
even have twitter i go dude sign up
right now and start posting this [__]
you can you meet people it's pretty
amazing um you know what's crazy also
somebody i'm pretty sure somebody sent
it to zuck
because uh somebody who's very close to
him like respects like was like yeah
this is awesome
um
and so i'm pretty sure that person was
going to share it with with him which is
kind of crazy right like i literally i
watched the keynote of him talking uh
you know he gave basically a 30 minute
presentation and i actually want to talk
about this so he gave a 30 minute
presentation
saying we rebranded to meta here's why
here's what it's going to be like
not just like here's not just like
here's new products we're going to build
but here's what the world is going to
look like here's what life is going to
look like it gave this cool presentation
i don't know did you see this
presentation
a little bit it bored the [__] out of me
oh really i thought it was amazing you
got bored from that
a little bit it's literally like
somebody opened the door and it's like
hey you want to see what life's going to
look like in 20 years yeah i just find
him to be incredibly unlikable
well yeah he's kind of robotic but like
uh so it's still a little bit hard to
watch
i
i definitely yeah there's definitely
some cringe factor for for sure but
um but the the funny thing is i saw that
and then i was supposed to have this
call with ben and ben's like oh i gotta
like
you know i gotta take care of the baby
real quick uh like just
you know i'll be online in like 25
minutes i was like okay cool i was like
all right i got 25 minutes to kill and i
just watched this thing and i just
tweeted it out and i like to me it was
like a throwaway thing it wasn't like a
planned drafted edited thing and so
anyways crazy how that works but i want
to talk about this um this meta thing so
not even
what um what he predicted or what kind
of zuck laid out but what do you think
about facebook changing the name of the
company in general and like
uh i have kind of a theory on why but
but i'd love to hear what you think
i think that
if i was facebook
and i wanted to recruit the best people
on earth
i would do
like
what i've learned running a business and
this is something that every business
says is they say like an entrepreneur of
a 20-person company you even tweeted
about ben levy um like i just call ben
like blank but what should i call him so
this is something that everyone says is
true but it's not which is that titles
titles matter people will be like oh
titles don't matter
um just call yourself anything no
they're actually really important and
they matter a ton even if you're a 10
person company
if i was zuck and i wanted to create a
company where people wanted to work
which i think they're struggling to
right now i would change the name of the
company and i would have a ceo of
facebook i would have a ceo of this a
ceo of that which means there's like a
vp there's like a president and that's
and then i would give all these people
their own kingdoms and that's how i
would continue to grow so that's what i
would do is i would if that's exactly
what facebook did or google so there's a
ceo of google there's a ceo of youtube a
ceo of this of that of that of that and
then which each ceo there's like a
hierarchy for people to climb and you
got to give these people these ladders
that's why i think it's a great idea
that's that's on point so so basically
i've heard i will call it maybe three or
four different theories so one theory is
what you made this up is is this real so
that's what i know that i i do in in
kind of nerd circles you know i've just
heard a couple people talk about this
and i was kind of like
here's what i think it is but let's
start with let's lay out the theory so
31 is it's a recruiting why would you do
this right they said it's a recruiting
thing
um and it's basically a mix of what you
said which is
when you create a parent company now you
have like
more you created basically another level
at the exact level you created one you
it's like your neck was compressed
and now it's stretched out and it's like
ah you just created this breathing room
so that person who's otherwise
vp
can now become ceo and it's like that
might be the difference between them
like i know uh for example the person
who who you know was head of or vp of i
don't look at her ceo ben look up fiji
fiji sumo's title so she was she was in
charge of big blue which is the facebook
app
and um
and then and there was chris cox before
her and they and they ran kind of like
multiple products they were kind of like
in charge of like the suite of products
um but their titles weren't ceo it was
something else and she left and now
she's the ceo of instacart so she like
left the big ship you know the the
trillion dollar company to go be the ceo
of a
maybe 10 or 20 billion dollar company i
don't know what's inside it's valued at
something like that
and um and so now you lose that key
talent and maybe it's because she looked
up and said this exact guy's never gonna
leave this guy was super young he loves
this [__] you know where where do i go
how do i go up i can't go up anymore um
and even the stock price we're already
at a trillion dollars what am i betting
on we go to 10 trillion like i need some
upside and i need some some resume
growth here so that's one theory i like
that theory i think that's true but i
wouldn't say it's the number one reason
okay so let's go to the other theories
then there's the the skeptical theory
which is
dude facebook's brand is trash it's the
philip morris of uh you know facebook
equals cigarettes and they're just
trying to run away from all the bad news
and all the bad branding and so they're
kind of pretty good theory
so a lot of people think that and
there's a there's a there's a subset on
that which is
if if mark hires a ceo of facebook the
app
then the person who get called into
senate is that person to go sit in front
of senate and talk all this stuff and
they can get sort of like hammered out
there but zuck as you know chairman or
whatever of of meta
it's like you know when the google guys
did this they sundar now or whatever has
to go
um go in front of congress and larry
page can just go and and he just you
know could be ceo of alphabet and not
have to worry about that stuff by the
way did you know that
did you know that one of the google
founders i don't know
i don't i think it's larry do you know
he can't speak
he's got like a voice problem sir sergey
he's gonna know he's larry it is larry
yeah i think it's larry so over over the
years if if you go and go to his name
type in like his name on youtube and
you'll see a video of him 10 years ago
and you could hear it progressing and
then like
maybe five years ago you're like oh this
is really bad i'm pretty sure at this
point he can't talk at all but if going
this is so interesting google his name
and watch a video of him and you in any
video that's online it's probably recent
enough that you can start hearing his
voice he you know i'm not making fun of
him but he sounds like kermit the frog
like it's a really weird voice for how
he looks it's definitely been that way
for a few years i think he can still
speak but it's basically it's uh his
vocal cords are like partially paralyzed
if i remember correctly yeah that's
crazy man so if i was him i wouldn't
want to go speak either i mean it seems
really embarrassing i mean he shouldn't
be embarrassed but i understand you know
so by the way i'm just reading it right
now it says 14 years ago he had a cold
and then he got like a horse a horse
voice from the cold and he just never
recovered he went to a doctor and they
said his left vocal cord was paralyzed
and it's a nerve problem
um that's causing your left vocal cord
not to move properly anymore
yeah like when i first heard him talk i
was like the video is broken right
because he's super soft spoken right so
you're like wow is this good it sounds
like he's speaking it sounds like the
video since
yeah it almost sounded like the video
was in slow motion or something it was
really uh
you know it's sad it sucks
yeah it's crazy and so i think it has
happened on his right vocal cord too now
hashimoto's thyroiditis that's wild yeah
it's it's [__] anyway but yeah so if i
was him i wouldn't want to speak in
front of the senate either and ben
looked it up fiji's title was head of
the facebook app so so the that's that's
one theory which is it's such bad news
as a rebrand i think one of the
cigarette companies rebranded to like
altria or altea or something like that
so it's like it's like reminiscent of
that
so okay so that's like another theory
and then there's the third theory which
is actually the theory that i subscribe
to
uh which is this is actually just a
mission shift
um and so
i remember when i worked at twitch
and this was the second year i was right
before i left so i was kind of like you
know basically i was on paternity leave
i wasn't even really working at twitch
at that time i was on paternity leave
and i was
thinking okay i think it's time for my
next thing
um
but i got a phone call from emmett who's
the ceo
and emmett's great and uh you know
i got a ton of respect for him and he
basically said hey i want to uh
i see he said he'd messaged me something
and said like hey do you have time to
talk today like
i uh want to bounce something off you
and he called me and he basically said
you know this funny thing has happened
which is that
like i think eight to ten years ago very
early days of twitch we had we set out
like this big north star mission which
was a million creators getting paid to
create on on the platform um
and so it was like 1 million he's like
and at that time we might have had like
you know we were in the thousands or
tens of thousands or something like that
like a million just seemed a million
people getting paid like earning money
doing this it just seemed like wild
and so um
he's like you know so so the million was
like super far away he's like and then
you know last year like we hit the
million and he's like it's this really
weird feeling like you you hit this
10-year goal
and there's like this amazing part of it
which is holy [__] we did it and then
there's this numb part of it which is
like wait it's like now what
what do you do when you hit the thing
that you thought was like you know if
it's like when elon takes a man to mars
okay what's the what's the next step
right it's like if you get to the moon
where you got to start thinking what do
i do now and so he said you know one of
the most danger he told me on the phone
he goes one of the most dangerous things
for a company is achieving your mission
because you have to reinvent your
mission you have to reinvent yourself
and think bigger he's like and so he was
like i want to brainstorm with you some
ideas on what that could be what could
be the mission for the company next 10
years and so we had a good good
brainstorm or whatever
and um and so i think that's what this
is i think facebook is now used by like
everybody with a cell phone uh you know
facebook or one of the facebook apps
they they the mission was connect you
know like uh connect the world or
whatever they literally did it they
connected the world everybody is using
like not only one but multiple products
so many people use facebook that when
sarah worked there
i think they were sending satellites to
india because they just literally needed
more people on the web in order to yeah
they ran out of ran out of people with
with internet and so they're like dude
you know
it's that moment where you're tam your
total addressable market becomes your
actual market share
it's insane and so um to the point where
i remember once we were having lunch
with uh alex the founder of calm and he
just started cracking up and i was like
what he goes i just realized he's like
dude think about how many facebook
accounts shut down to churn just due to
death he's like every day there's
probably like a million people who just
die and stop using the service and he
was just like tackling he's like that's
insane to me he's like that if you're at
that scale that's how many people yeah
that's pretty well literally just die
and stop using your service that's like
more people than ever have used our
product will die today on facebook
um so anyways i think that this is a
mission shift basically i think they
achieved the mission one and it's like
what's the point of the company now is
it just to make money and um and i think
a lot of people think zuckerberg is
pretty evil i i actually don't think
he's evil uh i do think he likes power
um as evidenced by like you go read
those early like text messages that got
leaked of him talking to his buddy at
college and he's like dude he's like you
know these dumb [__] are just giving me
all their information whatever like it
sounds really evil but i think he just
liked being kind of like the puppet
master a little bit
um but fundamentally i don't think he's
money hungry i don't think he's driven
by money um and early on i remember when
facebook ipod he put something in their
prospectus that i really liked and i
think other people kind of roll their
eyes if you just hate everything
facebook does but i thought it was
pretty cool he goes
we don't build great services to make
money we make money to build great
services um and he's like there's a big
import there's an important difference
between the two yes we care about money
but we care about money so that we have
the profits to invest in building great
services to hire the best people who can
build the greatest services and the
greatest products in the world and i
think that's what they're doing now he
said they're investing 10 billion
dollars this year
in their virtual reality augmented
reality stuff for for like you know kind
of the metaverse which is
an absurd amount of money to be
investing into this you know that's like
that's what some people think like you
know
this stuff is going to be worth someday
if you started a company in vr you'd be
hoping it'd be worth 10 billion someday
he's investing that as one year's r d
which is insane
i want to talk to you about a bunch of
different things but
but i want and i want to ask you after
your real estate guy your real estate
buddy but someone said they like when we
rambled about normal stuff and i want to
get we can make this really quick but
did you watch ufc on saturday
i did oh i watched okay part of it yeah
i watched hamza okay so i want fort lee
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter if
you're into ufc or not i want you all to
do this so a few weeks ago a few months
ago we talked about this woman named
rose
nama eunis nami gunas her name is thug
rose she's this little white-haired lady
with like a shaved head really cool and
she was muttering to herself like i'm
the best i'm the best before the before
the fight and it was inspirational it
was and then she knocked out this woman
and it was like inspirational because
she's very endearing she's very cute
like there's everything to like about
this woman
there's this guy who's kind of the same
thing but the opposite so there's this
guy that is about to be the best but
he's not the best first not the best yet
his name is komzat
okay and he's this
um
there's for some reason there's a huge
chechen
uh group of ufc fighters chechnya if you
don't know i don't want to sound like a
fool i'm not incredibly well researched
it's like a subsidiary of russia it's a
region of russia they're mostly i think
so they're they're they're white and
they look white but they're um devout
muslims and they're russian i don't know
how like if they consider them russia or
not but we americans would say oh you're
just a russian muslim
that's what they look like and they're
known to russell a lot of them are from
this area called dagestan where if you
imagine your head what afghanistan looks
like that's kind of what this area looks
like and it's in russia and they
basically have gone through just a ton
of war lately or in the last like 20
years 30 years so there's this guy named
kamzat and he had a cleft lip or
something like that so his lip is all
crooked and he is so scary looking
and he comes in and he he knows how to
speak english now but his attitude and
what he says he says the same thing who
do you want to fight next and he goes oh
brother i'll smash everyone i'm going to
kill everyone i'm going to take their
soul
and he's been saying that this whole
time and he's been in four fights in the
ufc and he's been punched in the face
one time
this weekend
which is absurd this weekend he fought
the best chinese guy
uh i forget his last name with lee he's
just he's a little bit older but he's
considered the best out of china and he
picked him up and he walked over to the
side of the cage where dana was and he
yells to dana get off your phone watch
this and he gets on top of the guy and
chokes him unconscious
and
did so and in the interview afterwards
in the ring and outside the ring he goes
brother i'm just here to smash everyone
and kill people
everyone brother i kill everyone i'm
here to kill everyone i love this i'll
kill everyone that's all he was saying
and they go what are you gonna are you
gonna fight the number one person he
goes well they're going to have to give
me the number one person because i'm
going to kill everyone no one will be
alive and then
he said something he goes he goes uh
they go you know where did you get this
mentality or something he goes i'm crazy
man he goes
he goes i just you go he goes you don't
you say all the best people are crazy
you can't be not crazy and be the best
when there's crazy people out there who
want to be the best and i just thought
that's not true it's absolutely true i'm
a gangster he goes i'm a gangster i'm
crazy and i think there's two there's a
few things to learn here the first is
i think a lot of that is born i think a
lot of that is just an act that you've
turned on because in his case i imagine
he's seen a lot of tragedy and like
[__] war and he like created this
tough guy persona in order just to
survive you know he
and the second thing is i think you
could tell yourself that consistently
and you kind of can become it and the
third thing is this these guys these
zagastani guys and also
for some reason this weekend all
russians won peter yan won he's russian
all these russians they're crushing it
they've got something in them i don't
know what this russian attitude is that
i've noticed about these guys but it's
this it's this very quiet although comes
out even though he talks a lot of [__]
he's still really quiet it's this quiet
subtle confidence and i love it
if i watch them their videos over and
over again fedor had it they've got this
quiet confidence and i'm in love with
that i'm in love with it
yeah they have a tenacity that's pretty
crazy the um i was watching uh i was
going through i was just browsing on
tiktok and this clip came up related
that um like in the nba most of the nba
is not like that uh like
hey there's not many russians in the nba
but b
um kind of silly ufc is one of the only
sports where people go and say i want to
kill everybody
in any other sport they don't really say
that on in the press conference right
they might say it trash talk on the
field when there's no microphone to pick
it up but in the ufc they just literally
say it to the reporter the reporter
writes it down and publishes the post or
whatever and it's one of the only sports
it's one of the only sports you can't
play
right
yeah yeah you can't like play it you
know it's like if it's like something
but
something that's going to two cool
little nuggets here so early on the the
founding story of the ufc is pretty
pretty wild but it was started by some
somebody else and then dana white who's
currently the president of the ufc
pretty famous guy he's like a part of
the show basically um he goes to every
single event he sits cage side he's he's
every like and they do like an event in
a different place every weekend and so
this guy's he's now a billionaire um and
he
uh so and he's he's a very outspoken guy
like
uh imagine the commissioner of your
favorite sport you know they're usually
a pretty buttoned up guy usually
ex-lawyer you know they they just say
you know we as the nfl are committed to
upholding integrity and
dana white will post like oh this
fight's going to be awesome and some
somebody in an instagram comment will be
like this fight sucks or that's too
expensive for the pay-per-view and then
he's a [__] clown yeah he'll
literally be like you [__] clown like
shut up you [__] clown and then
that's like he says that it's like what
ceo of what company is able to just say
that to their potential customers it's
insane the whole sports savage but he
said something early on because
the bet that he made the investment that
they made they bought the ufc for about
two million dollars and it wasn't his
money he convinced his two kind of
childhood friends the fertittas who own
casinos that's their background that's
how they made their wealth
convince them let's buy the ufc and then
they ended up pouring in like 50 or 60
million dollars at a loss to keep it
alive to promote the thing and he kept
believing kept believing kept believing
they kept pouring millions and millions
of dollars in and it looked like it was
not gonna work and then it has now since
turned around as a public company and
it's you know it's all working now they
sold it for for you know over four
billion dollars yeah i think it and i
was and i was looking at it it's a great
company it makes like
three or four hundred million a year in
profit and they asked them dana what
gave you the faith that this business
would work when all the evidence just
said the guy who tried the guy who did
this before me failed
um nobody else has done this in america
and um and you guys are bleeding like 40
50 60 million dollars why did you
continue he goes because i get people
and he goes i understand humans he goes
let's say we're out on a playground and
there's a football game going on over
there there's a soccer game over here
there's a basketball court over there
people shooting hoops
and i said
oh my god that russian guy's fighting
that chinese guy guess where everybody's
attention goes he goes everybody looks
and then everybody runs over to watch
the fight he goes that's how humans are
wired you can't help but turning and
looking when a fight breaks out and that
was the whole like
thesis that was the the underlying
psychological nugget i loved that uh you
know that that that is how simple
he was thinking and he goes he goes and
he goes and by the way this is a sport
that transcends every country yeah
football is huge in america go to the uk
nobody cares we have fighters who are
like the pride of the uk it's a huge
we're huge in in the uk we're huge in
australia we're huge in africa we're
huge in china like this can get bigger
than any one of those sports because we
can tap into the global population
because fighting one person punching
another is a universally known sport you
don't need to even know the rules it's
not like basketball or football or
baseball like it's like if i try to
watch cricket i don't know what's going
on i don't know the rules but with two
people are fighting i understand the
premise
i get what's going on and uh and it's
like you know this historic barbaric
thing so anyways i love that business
side of the ufc as well so if you're a
ufc person
that you know i'm talking about if
you're not that was pretty cool and this
weekend there's a couple things there's
i'll say it real quick that the main
thing is this guy kamar oozeman african
immigrant comes to america during
college kicks ass the american dream
he's fighting against a a devout maga
trump supporter so that story is very
fun the second fight is rose now younes
who i like she's fighting uh the best
one from china she's they're both
amazing and then the third one is like
these both midwestern hard-working guys
who are just going to stand there and
bash you they're just like bangers they
just stand there and bash each other's
brains and so that's the cool fight this
weekend um all right what do you got
uh let's do something else let's switch
topics here you have a couple things on
here let's do a quick idea actually so
um so ben had this idea that i liked he
goes
he goes you know my brother is a real
estate agent and he goes real estate
agents are really competitive with each
other you know in any given city they're
they're fighting for kind of like the
pie is this big
you know it's either my client or yours
there's not a whole lot of uh
you know there's not a whole lot of ways
for real estate agents to collaborate
with each other some like to do deals
together like if i'm the buy side and
you're the sell side great we can i'm
confident we can get our clients to
hammer out a deal but for the most part
it's a very kind of doggy dog world all
agents are like the sports agents
whatever but he goes with real estate
agencies like there's something
interesting that might be a niche little
business and he goes uh and so i called
it real estate buddy which is basically
when you're let's say you're a real
estate agent in florida or right now
california real estate agent california
and a bunch of people are moving to
texas that agent in california is not
going to help you find a home in texas
but maybe i helped you buy your your
california home and you don't know any
agents in texas so what if i had
basically a buddy in every state
that if my client is moving there i can
pass you to them
and and basically i get a share of the
commission and they get a free referral
free trusted client basically that
somebody else has put the time and
energy in to build up trust and so you
could create this network of leads
basically and uh and partnerships across
borders where there actually is a big
incentive to collaborate because
otherwise both sides benefit from this
whereas normally it's extremely
competitive world so i thought that's a
little interesting of a niche business
maybe something like that exists i'm not
super deep in that world have you ever
you used bigger pockets
like to learn you mean
yeah do you know bigger pockets pocket
sizes it's like a real estate kind of
like media company
forum plus podcasts
buying real estate
i think that could be potentially a huge
business i don't think it is huge but i
bet it could be so if you look at the
reason i see them all the time is when
we look at our podcast rankings we're
like on a good week we'll be like
10 11 12 13 14 15 in the bid business
categories on a bad week will be 40 50.
and bigger pockets is like always number
three and then they have another one
that's like number six and they got
another one that's like number 11. like
they're always in the top 10 most listed
podcast bigger pockets has three or four
of them and then they got this forum
that costs
well it's free but
you could sign up and get extra stuff
i'm a 300 a year paying member
and i think what these guys are doing is
they're like built this business
and media arm or whatever and then they
just use all their cash flow to go and
buy more real estate
um
it's it's an amazing company i love
bigger pockets i think if you want to
build a community
um
this is the company like make money from
it this style and you want to do it like
with a style where you get a lot of
people these guys are 100 this is the
model this is the perfect model on how
to do it yeah that's actually a great
point because bigger pockets has existed
for a while and it's always been
important the main guy i think joshua
josh dorkan or sometimes his name he
sold it at some point so i think i don't
know who owns it now let me see if i can
find out
um so basically he sold the thing not
for a ton if i remember correctly
um mccarthy not a good thing to sell
and this is such a valuable property so
it was just like a forum yeah and um i
don't know the full story i mean he
could he could raise this is like
angelus he could raise like a massive
fund
yeah exactly and so i think he had like
a med
there was some story like he had like a
medical emergency for his kid or
something so he had to take time off and
then he ended up selling it i don't know
how it all went down but i think you
could compete with this i think you
could build a better bigger pockets um
it would be hard i'm not saying it's not
easy but i think that they would be
extremely valuable and if you're gonna
if you're gonna build a community or a
media company in any niche
this is one that i would i would bet on
because um
you know if you're not gonna go for
something new and sexy like crypto or
whatever you know this is where a lot of
money is to be made and there's always a
new batch of people that want to learn
about making money in real estate how to
buy real estate
there's always a new group of people who
are looking to like you know learn
connect blah blah blah
and um and maybe bigger pockets is
pretty like established with its crew
but you know who's number two if i just
said who's number two behind bigger
pockets certainly there is somebody
but i don't think it's as household of a
name right now and i wonder if you could
take some other angle and do it by the
way can you talk dude wait let me look
let me tell you about something that i
let me talk about something real quick
something that you've never uh
maybe you're about to say what i'm gonna
say a house something that's not a
household name and is huge in our little
world there's this group it's a guy or a
group of guys called angels this is
exactly what i was gonna ask you about
okay i've gotta tell you i'm getting
dinner with these guys tonight
okay so angels like no offense angels i
think you guys are wonderful i've met
you it's a really weird name at first so
i guess it's not spelled this way i
guess it just means gay angel
um okay so it's this i think it's one
person who started it lorenzo i think
his name is he's gay i guess based off
of uh doing some research on him and i
think he was a successful entrepreneur
i'm meeting him tonight i don't know his
whole background but he started this
group called angels
and i believe it was an email list of
gay
give the headline first why is this
interesting and then didn't give the
back yeah you're right so it's this
group of people it's this guy who's got
this it's not a fun but it's like a gr
investment group
and this year alone
the rumor is that they're gonna invest
around four to five hundred million
dollars
and previously they've invested
collectively over the past few years
like 300 million dollars so like next
year two years their total investment is
gonna be like a billion dollars which is
basically like a three billion dollar
fund kind of like that you invest if you
have a three billion dollar fund i would
imagine you invested over five years so
like that's like the numbers we're
talking here
and basically it would be like a very
large
this is startup investing so this is
like a very large technology fund that i
haven't ever heard one of the bigger and
it seems like a niche fringe thing it's
like oh that's cool like a lgbtq fund
what do you have like a two million
dollar fund and you're you're investing
in you know
some cool companies it's like no how are
they deploying how are they getting 400
million dollars in a year to deploy and
then how are they
i don't think they get any money if you
google it's it's spelled angels like
gain like g-a-i-n
and then joel's angels and if you look
at their portfolio and if you just
google angels and click news you'll see
all these tech crunch articles that it
says you know and this company raises
money from addressing this this this and
angels this this this and angels will
say for every article and if you go to
their port do you see their portfolio
pages yeah it's legit yeah dude they're
in everything gadgels isn't everything
they're in everything and what they do
is they find companies and they write a
page about it and then they um send it
out to an email list and people invest
and they get a 20 carry in it and they
um
take also a fee of like eight or ten
thousand dollars per deal that they take
out of that money and they use that to
as their like finders fee so they could
pay their lawyers and things like that
and that's the whole business model and
they've got like this web of like five
or six or seven people who will
also send the deals that angels gets
access to to their audience and those
people who send it to their audience
also get a stake in the of the carry um
and that's a very simple business model
are most of the investors gay or that's
just the most of the people who started
are gay what's the stick can i do it if
i don't yeah so here's the
yeah so here's the thing why it's kind
of crazy is it must have started like
they like mostly invested into gay and
lesbian and transsexual or uh you know
what whatever uh lgbt uh you know
whatever the the uh
what is it
sorry i'm not me l b
l i'm just struggling l g b t q
yes is that it that's the new i thought
that there was a really fun intro music
i think maybe you just stumbling over
lgbtq is perfect no i'm just whatever
lgdb i just can't say it properly
that
so it started with that that was their
thing but then
like they invested like they've invested
yeah they invested in hone which is the
company you and i invested for
testosterone yeah and
that's like a pretty masculine male i
guess you could say like well maybe if
you're transitioning you would want to
take testosterone but um
they invest in like lift so like i don't
know where like how the the lg d
whatever i'm just like just skip it lg
lgbtq
thing lines up with the with the whole
with like other companies but that was
definitely their angle
and it's not anymore but it's a great
angle because you know there's not a lot
of gay and lesbian investors and then
they're like hey look that's our whole
stick like let us in i understand it
totally works
do you remember uh
do you remember when you stopped using
gay as a uh as a term for like uh you
know just meaning like whatever like
something is lame or something is stupid
oh yeah in high school
and do you remember what got you to stop
or what when you realize like oh wait
that's not cool just like when i had
like gay friends i was like oh that's
not very nice is it and uh
and then like
i talked to my nephews and they're like
in there sarah's in there sarah's
nephews and they're like 14 15 and 13.
and i was just curious and i was like
hey do you guys ever insult someone or
does anyone ever insult someone for
being gay and they're like what do you
mean i'm like you know like do you ever
say like yeah
yeah like you know you say like hey man
that's really gay you're gay and they go
but like why is it bad to be gay and i
was like
it's not you just answered you just
answered my question thank you and they
just it's just not part you know what i
mean when you're kids when we were
younger that's
and it was crazy yeah it's i don't think
young people like
insult people for being gay i think it's
pretty crazy yeah i think that means
like in 20 years because probably when i
was 10 that's like what everybody in my
school was you know that was like a
common thing to say and so i think that
means in 20 years it went from
just common and people did it without
even thinking to like
it would now be kind of disgusting it
would be like it's not even like a it's
not even an argument it's like wait why
would we do that like what i would do
you know like why would i why would i
try to use that as an insult that
doesn't make any sense i like in my head
there's like the n word and then there's
like the f word
like
you know what i mean like i would never
you know what i mean if i heard someone
say that i would be like flabbergasted
i'd be like what yeah it'd be like when
i was a kid it was like the word like
you know if you said the word if it was
like this that was like the c word now
like i wouldn't say uh
australian people they say
yes but like it's yeah it is kind of
crazy how that how it's changed i mean
obviously it's good but yeah i remember
as a kid
we just got to give a shout out and then
the person who first told me like hey by
the way you know that's not cool right
um i was
uh it was this guy who who actually just
just i think yesterday or two days ago
or something the news came out that he's
in gay he's gay and he's engaged to uh
to this guy that's been dating for 11
years so the actor cal pen
he um
uh when i was a kid i was in a movie and
he was my older brother in the movie and
so we like would hang out on the set all
the time
and i remember saying it when whatever i
was just calling so i was trying to say
something was stupid or lame or whatever
weird i don't know what i was trying to
say i was just a little kid it's
probably like in sixth grade or
something and he was just like um he was
the first person that i'd ever even
brought my attention to he goes you know
that's not uh like you shouldn't say
that when you just mean something's like
weird or not cool uh like you shouldn't
say gay and you should say something
else and he wasn't out that time i don't
know if he even knew at the time but he
brought that to my attention and i felt
i remember feeling so dumb because i
looked up to this guy i thought he was
so cool and i was so nervous
yeah he was totally nice he kind of like
he was hanging like big brother do you
yeah he big brother he was just like yo
like by the way like you know you
shouldn't do that like think about it
blah blah blah and i was like oh that
makes total sense like i never even
thought about this like
and then in that time and even in my my
world where i lived houston texas it's
not like even like i went back it's not
like i was the last one to know nobody
even really thought about it but he was
like in hollywood and i think it was
like you know people on the west coast
were people on the coast tend to be like
a little more like kind of forward and
liberal and progressive with that type
of stuff so um so i remember hearing
that and being like oh man i just made a
fool of myself and like yeah that's
silly i don't know why i do that and i
just stopped after that and so it came
full circle
uh yesterday but anyways we can do
another another topic what else you got
all right let's do one more um
all right i'm gonna tell you about um
actually do you have one you want to do
you want me to go let's do this one
that's about uh companies so i had this
idea i i don't even know what it is but
i was reading that tech uh tesla was
doing something called gigafest do you
know what gigafest is
yes so basically if i remember correctly
they and a lot of people like liberal
media got angry because they're like
tesla's throwing a a festival and during
a pandemic but basically they rented out
a town in germany and they're doing like
a conference or a festival
and like what's happening at is it like
drinking in music or is it like car
technical stuff do you know
i have no idea so okay honestly it
doesn't even matter what it was i just
saw the name and i thought ah man
tesla's doing another smart thing like
they basically took oktoberfest and they
just rebranded it for their thing and
it's gonna i assumed it's gonna be some
combination of like fun
as well like you know between music and
food and drinks and all that as well as
like you know things that are relevant
to you know building cool cars and then
recruiting talent and just building the
brand and having people have a great
experience at the brand and i started
thinking
why don't more companies do this and at
first i thought well certainly they're
not the only ones and i started thinking
about other examples of this so there's
like the macy's day parade which i don't
even know like
how that got invented i don't know i
don't know the back story but since i
was like i was a kid i remember that
there's always the macy's day parade on
tv
and it's like why did macy's get in on
that or we've talked about michelin star
restaurants right michelin tires uh the
tire company basically inventing a a
food restaurant ranking system so that
you would have a reason to go drive
you know far out places to go try these
amazing restaurants they created demand
for for driving long distances through
the michelin star and they just got
their name and and all that
and um and you know there's the forbes
30 under 30 list and then there's like
in san francisco every year if you live
in san francisco you know dream force
it's this like
full like kind of it shuts down half the
city and there's sort of like a parade
and there's like big bands like you two
come and perform but it's like for the
most boring thing it's like a sales crm
dude do you want to know why people most
people more people don't do this
yeah i think a lot of people actually
try and it just doesn't work all right
so
um the fortune 500
fortune 500 is that basically just means
the top 500 companies in the world at
this point do you even think fortune 500
means fortune magazine
all right sometimes it does over
overtake the brand like michelin
michelin star means more to me than
michelin tires
do you
when you think have you ever
shopped at a macy's
of course i've shopped at a bases before
yeah have you been at a macy's in 20
years
not 10 yeah 10 years probably cut off so
a lot of so there's one i think a lot of
times people do this
i always work with like creative people
and
maybe i'm just sometimes a pessimist
around this stuff a lot of times they
give me these ideas and i'm like this is
just [__] stupid and i don't think
this is going to increase sales i'm just
trying to survive at the moment
and
and it doesn't work i agree it's not for
when you're in survival mode which is
where i spent most of my career in
startups is like
you're you're not in survival mode or
you're in survival mode if you don't
turn if you don't make this work it's
going to just die so you don't have time
to plan a parade with a music festival
and like all the stuff that wouldn't
make any sense
and here's the other reason why this
isn't a good idea though
well this isn't a good idea a lot of
times because
most companies they're just [__] lame
like imagine like
um i'm trying to think like just like
this window blind company hunter douglas
like they're gonna have like what a
blind fest like i don't know i mean i
guess i think there's some cool [__]
like you know blendtec
the blender have you heard of blendtec
the blender and they had will it blend
that was awesome i loved willow blend
remember that youtube channel yeah yeah
of course
i love will it blend but a lot of stuff
is just lame and i don't want to
celebrate it now a few boring things
that i think could work is um
uh what's that vacuum company everyone
loves dyson dyson yeah dude i'm i'm
about to i'm like been staying up at
night i wonder if i'm gonna buy one of
these 700 vacuums have you ever used one
of them the handheld one
yeah it's like this amazing one yeah i
have that one amazing everyone you you
have one did you pay 700 bucks for it i
feel so satisfied dude i feel like i get
700 bucks of value every time i use it
so like dyson has like is like boring
and and i dig i would do that um i can't
i have to think of like what else is
like boring and awesome but dude any any
company can do this all you have to do
is attach your boring name to
awesomeness and it does work it does
work to an extent now it's not going to
turn a bad company into a good company
but it does take a boring company and
make them slightly less boring it makes
them more relevant and in general i just
feel like those same dollars just go
further so like i see so many dumb
billboards or uh just like useless
events or useless like ads um you know
on the all over the internet and i just
sort of think man you know for like two
hundred thousand dollars you can throw
like a whole music festival you could
you could do like some amazing things
with 200 000 and that's what they'll
spend yeah but i don't want to go to
like
flora or clorox bleach and imagine
dragons like i just don't give a [__]
you
know what i mean you might
did you want to go to a tiger
restaurants reviewed entire entire
company's restaurant review reviews no
you didn't maybe but like when i think
of like
like clorox and like the killers like i
don't think like i'm gonna buy more
bleach
dude mr brightside although maybe maybe
i don't know oh that's a good point walk
right into that one i don't know i'm not
sure if it could work maybe um but i
think and i also think a lot of those
things i don't think they're as
successful often like whenever i was
thinking of like fortune 500 or michelin
i'm like
i don't [__] that don't associate
that with the magazine the magazine's
still going to go bankrupt anytime
um so anyway i don't know like i think
the victoria's secret fashion show is a
good example also of like
going overboard on these kind of events
and like just put your you're not
directly trying to sell your thing
you're creating a spectacle you're
attracting the type of people you want
like for example
we have an ad budget for this podcast
where they're like dude hubspot is great
they're generous they're like you guys
are in our our hubs
podcast network we want to help you grow
so they gave us a little bit of a little
bit of
cash a lot of money and i can't think of
a thing to do with it
exactly because and what's the plan
right now the plan is to go spend a [__]
ton of it on spotify ads
right and that might work and uh and
other podcasts
and other podcast platforms and it might
work i don't know we'll see i might
still work very poorly so i'm saying
with that same amount of money can i say
how much money or no
uh
hundreds of thousands of dollars a
quarter so hundreds of thousands of
dollars maybe maybe we could say like uh
in the range of a million dollars a year
right so i don't know like let's take
our audience our audience is kind of
this hustler type mindset our audience
is this person who likes to they like
investing they like building [__] they
want to make money um they they like
hearing about billion dollars companies
and billionaires and things like that
like what could we do that would just
get i don't know like if we got 50 000
people to pay attention to something i
think that would be a huge win right so
what would be a either an event or a
stunt or something that's of service to
people the equivalent of what red bull
did right like red bull was like dude
we're we're an energy drink we're all
about sort of like
you know this is kind of badass
lifestyle all right we're going to put a
guy in a wing suit we're going to take a
guy like what can we do though
well this is thinking about this i don't
know like i
just um okay let me think of one i think
that we could do um
what are people who are in startups what
are people who are into building
businesses what are they what are they
super into that that's true
i've gone through this mental exercise
and i'm it's
okay i have a dumbbell for me i have a
dumb simple one i remember these people
set up a um
a headshots uh by the way your computer
screen is like covering your face or
something oh there you go um i remember
this uh
like a fitness company did this they
they parked their van outside of the uh
salesforce tower and everybody who's
coming in they're like do you want to
get your body scanned real quick or do
like this bmi test to do this test i'll
tell you what i loved
hired two people to stand outside the
[__] like tower and they just got a
bunch of people in and they like while
they were there they said what is this
all about who's doing this why do i get
this free thing and uh they got to learn
about their learn about their body while
then being so upsold into like signing
up for these scans and personal training
and a gym membership after that
and um i saw somebody else do this with
headshots they're like you know what
like your picture online just like looks
like [__] sean but what do you do
what's that
so what do you want to do for us yeah so
i'm saying we could come up with
something where let's say we had i don't
know if you've ever seen those like 360
degree cameras uh you can rent these
things for like a thousand dollars we
could have a pop-up in a city in in in
new york and all you got to do is if you
show that you're subscribed to the pod
you can get a free epic headshot done
for you and we just pop them up you know
near downtown where a bunch of people
live and that thing would cost us you
know i don't know three grand total for
the day but might have like a thousand
people have like a unique experience or
two thousand people have a unique
experience or maybe we could have like a
blimp going over you know going over
miami and the blimp is going to you know
airdrop you know some like cash or the
blimp is going to display some qr code
or something like that and there's a
giveaway inside i don't know like
something to drop million dollar bills
yeah some kind of stunt or whatever like
let's say um something that's like on i
hear you i'm on board i've just been
going through this and i'm like what is
worth pulling off like these are bad
ideas i gotta admit the ideas i had just
now are basically okay but i feel like
if i brainstorm for an hour
which i'm gonna do i feel like we come
up with a great idea and it's a better
use i'll do the same than the ads
i'll do the same i think i think it
requires both to be honest and i'll do
the same i think and this is like a good
example of whenever i talk to people and
they're like well i'll start this
company once i get funding i'm like if
you had the money you wouldn't even know
what to do trust me the money's not the
issue right and that's how i feel right
now i'm like the marketing budget is not
the issue yeah i'm like we got the money
we got the people i just don't know
which is kind of [__] up ramit talks
to people about this all the time he's
like once you're rich what are you gonna
do and people actually struggle with
this all the time right i struggle with
it i had this uh phrase i used to say at
our startup which is uh you can always
run out of money but you can never
declare creative bankruptcy and that was
that was always my rule was like
i cannot have a conversation with
somebody who says i i can't think of an
idea i don't know what else we could do
it's like you've declared creative
bankruptcy and like now you must go out
that door and never return again and and
and that's just my rule
so even if those guys
i don't declare bankruptcy those guys at
outside magazine asked us if we wanted
to do the adventure i don't think you
replied yet by the way not yet i sent
you do you see it
okay and they're like well what else
they're like what else do you want to do
and i'm like
oh i i have no idea i i i feel like such
a punk i can't think
when like they're like well we can go
anywhere as long as you're there and
back in three days i can't think of a
thing
it's [__] up like maybe okay who does
our audience look up to warren buffett
like he auctions off his like lunch
thing every year for like 100 grand or
whatever it's like dude something
there's no way it's only a hundred grand
i think it is it might even be less but
like i know uh like andrew wilkinson did
his i think it was like it was like i
don't know two grand or something to get
lunch with him you know how many people
would want to do that like we could just
host these we could get people to like
come and be able to hang out have a
lunch with chamoth or something like
that we could do
a giveaway that is we spend the money
here but then we dangle that in front of
people in order to get them interested
and excited about what we're doing now
those are kind of disconnected to what
we're doing but
i refuse to declare creative bankruptcy
is my my answer
we just got to think about it because
this it's been bothering me as well
where i'm like
what
what should we do because if you if
you're listening
imagine this we have hundreds of
thousands of dollars of budget
and we we want a whole bunch more people
to uh subscribe to the podcast and just
get down with the mission like realize
that there's a cool podcast out there
that they might like the reason you like
it there's a whole bunch of other people
that would like it for that same exact
reason they just don't listen to it yet
they've never heard it they don't know
that they should try it and so how would
you turn hundreds of thousands of
dollars into hundreds of thousands of
subscribers is the question and um and
so you know if you have ideas obviously
my ideas kind of suck sam refusing to
have an idea right now so we need we
need ideas
uh ben what do you think we should do
like the teacher calls on you and the
worst part no no no no this is good
because i was actually talking about
this this morning with uh
darren and jonathan but um
it's hard
here's one idea that we had was
we had this uh tick tock go not viral
but it did well on tick-tock
did you see that sean what was it
it was a rob durdeck thing um
what's his name jacob like texted me on
saturday night and he was like hey made
this and posted on tick tock got like
100 000 views yeah
which is like good so what we were
saying is what if we just put up 10 or
20 000 and just said
hey we're gonna put out the video files
from my first million anyone can access
the raw video files
and uh if you want to make content for
us great and at the end of the month
we'll give 10 or 20 000 to whoever gets
the most views on tick tock or instagram
reels
like a 99 designs contest that's not a
bad idea
that's actually a really good idea 20
grand to it and in order to be submitted
to the contest you have to um
you have to post it on twitter or
instagram yeah
and uh that's a great idea actually so a
consistent 20 grand a month contest for
the best clip
yeah
you can produce it you can just put it
out there because you have a big
audience but like whatever yeah do
whatever you want
that's actually brilliant right i've
seen i think that's the greatest idea
yet
right right he almost went greatest idea
ever he threw yet in there just to save
himself i was so close
yeah let's do that all right i'm going
to publicly brainstorm the ideas on
twitter that's how that's how we're
going to do this no i'm going to add
that one to it though i'm going to
create a thread i'm gonna add these
ideas to it and then i'm just gonna
continue until we have a winning idea
it's just it's a rolling twenty thousand
dollars and every single month one
person gets twenty thousand dollars and
the criteria is the people who are
posting the best most interesting most
viewed
mfm video content my other idea is i
guess i'm just into contests but it's
like hey if you want to join this
contest show up to downtown
um
preferably somewhere where not a lot of
people are from so like st louis
cleveland
austin whatever and uh austin actually
austin's a bad idea but um okay we're
gonna give you a category so it might be
food it might be exercise and fitness
but
you have 24 hours and whoever can make
the most money wins this contest and
will give you an extra 20 000
essentially an entrepreneurship contest
i got a better idea
[__] your idea here's a better idea
[Laughter]
all right here's a great idea okay so uh
sam how much does it cost to um to
sponsor like an open bar at a bar uh
like set up a bar chat let's actually
let's say
let's do this there's
we pick 10 cities around the country
and we say hey in these ten cities
if you're one of us
there is a place where you can go and
you can hang out with other people who
are like that like like us at the ball
uh uh like you know like you have heard
you could we could have basically say
hey we do a lot of for three grand
yeah exactly we're gonna put up fifteen
hundred dollars and we're gonna do this
in ten cities and we're gonna do this
every friday for the next uh you know
let's call it three months or whatever
it's like you know the winter the
winterfest and we say great we're going
to do that so we're going to do that 12
times that's 180 grand but basically
you've created a
and all you have to do to get to redeem
your free drinks to redeem a drink is
you just got to show you're subscribed
to the pod show bartender boom you get
it we just called
we have cool bars so like whatever's
like your favorite bar in austin your
favorite bar in new york your favorite
bar in san francisco whatever and we
just make that our little watering hole
and people who are into our [__] can go
and hang out there and it's not that
it's like the biggest mass idea but the
spark that would come from a bunch of
people a bunch of our fans getting to
know each other hanging out having
drinks bringing their friends i think a
lot of good would come of that a lot of
goodwill would i don't think that's not
that expensive
i think that's worth doing i would say
that the uh video bounty is to me the
most interesting
i think that's like
wildly interesting yeah bars that's not
a bad idea i've done that for years and
years on all types of stuff it worked
really well for product hunt it worked
well for us yeah it works what have you
done in that
um
well like for the hustle we've done
meetups forever and then when i started
my roommate business we had meetups
every single week for like two years and
so it's basically anyone who's ever
looking for a roommate you come
that day
and we'll have a party with like 150
people who are also looking for housing
right and in order to come you got to
download our app
and um another one that does this by the
way
it's like it's like physically hard i
remember being like i was like exhausted
all the time yeah for sure i remember um
this agency reached out and they had
emailed us before being like hey we're a
creative ad agency it's like uh yep into
the into the trash pile like i don't i
don't know you i don't this is just some
outbound sales thing whatever i don't
care
and one reach down they go they they
sent um
they sent a package with invites like
they sent us like a physical mail to our
office there's a bunch of flyers inside
cheap flyers you know just flyers
whatever they said hey uh these are
these are ticket entries so this gets
you entry to this party tonight um as
well as a free drink um we rented out
butter this bar in san francisco that's
like pretty famous and um
and they go we're having a meme battle
tonight it's like a rap battle but for
memes and we're like what and basically
um they got like they and then they
would email the office manager and they
say hey did you get our package we sent
over a bunch of invites make sure that
people know that's for you guys you guys
can come and get you know free drink and
it's great you know send five or six
people to have a great time and happy
hour today and so they all did was an
email and a flyer they sent that and
then i went there and it's basically
like they've rented out the bar it was a
tuesday night so like bar was like yeah
sure you know it's all yours go ahead um
and they basically had a projector on
the screen and they had a guy dressed up
as a cat and a person dressed up as a
dog and um and they would go it was the
battle was it was a five-round battle
and basically one would show a funny
video clip like a tic toc length thing
and then the other person would show it
and then the crowd had like that's
awesome little handles where they could
vote for the dog or the cat like who's
who's was funnier and it would it would
go five rounds and then the winner would
win at the end and that was it was just
silly and then the whole shtick was the
guy would come on at the end he'd be
like hey by the way that one that third
one that was actually a viral video we
made we're rubber republic we make
amazing viral videos um eight out of ten
videos we do get over a million views
like we're good at this [__] we've done
it for these companies uh enjoy
yourselves tonight and if any of you
guys ever want to have a video go viral
come find me or the guy dressed up as
the cat
and i was like and we worked with them
we did a video with them it got over a
million views and it was not the one
where you talked about drawing dicks all
over bebo yeah yeah exactly that was bro
so they made that video for us and so we
um and so they were so good and i was
like oh this little sales funnel they
did was actually genius um that's pretty
good you know because one client to them
is worth tens of thousands of dollars so
you know renting out this bar and
inviting people from these 20 companies
and just hoping one of them ends up with
you as a as a client is a great way to
go
all right well let's do ben let's let's
can we please make one of them happen
[Laughter]
yeah down let's do it all right
[Music]